Known as "The God of Lightning," Hajime Kashimo
has returned after four hundred years of abject
silence to exact vengeance upon one specific
man. This isn't any ordinary, bottom of the
barrel Miwa level slop of a character. Hajime
Kashimo was undoubtedly the strongest man of
his time and someone Kenjaku specifically
sought out to be apart of his culling game.
However, Sukuna never existed
in that time and perfection was
unattainable for Hajime. Now given
the chance at redemption its time
to witness what it means to have
perfected the use of curse energy.
Turning and seeing someone
approaching him at a high speed now,
Sukuna tells them that he
better not let them down!
Flashing into the sky we see that
without any time for anyone to
mourn or feel sorrow for Gojo's death,
the one that came in to take his place
against the KING OF CURSES, WAS NO OTHER
THAN, THE THUNDER GOD, HAJIME KASHIMO!!
Chapter 237
Hovering 203 meters off the ground,
Kashimo himself is surprised when he
notices an object falling from even
further up. Atop that meteor-sized
piece of ice was none other than
the frozen queen herself, Uraume!
Getting surprised herself, above Uraume appeared
Hakari, yelling out that she won't be going
anywhere. Not interested at all in taking on the
special grade sorcerer, Uraume prepares her ice
formation, while simultaneously Hakari pulls up
his hands and activates his Domain Expansion.
Even though Hakari was able to trap the ice queen
within his own domain, the large block of ice that
she stood on kept plummeting towards the earth
below. Down below, of course, was none other
than the king of curses who began extending
his hand towards the now melting iceberg.
Now, like a torrential ocean wave, all of the ice
melts into water under an endothermic reaction,
allowing the one-handed demon to grab a
certain object. So, remember back to when
Yorozu tried to show Sukuna love but failed.
Well, in the end, and in a similar way to Mai,
she used her innate technique creation to use her
remaining cursed energy to create a certain item.
Now with this dagger-like item clenched firmly
in the hand of the one she used to love,
it's revealed that what Yorozu created
was a replica of an ancient item Sukuna
used to wield. The cursed tool Kamutoke. This
tool's ability seems to be one that allows the
user to control some form of electricity.
Within milliseconds of receiving the tool,
Sukuna launches a blast towards his opponent,
which hilariously enough is perfectly countered
by the effects of Kashimo’s own curse energy.
Speaking up now, Kashimo asks the king of curses
if he earned the title of the strongest or was he
simply born with unbeatable prowess. Not actually
having a clue himself, Sukuna answers that he
can't say much, but what he can say is that
he was born cursed, an unwanted little wretch.
Stopping myself for a moment, this really makes
me question if he was born of a human and cursed
spirit, possibly in a similar way to that of Choso
or even Yuji. Was he useless at birth like Toji,
Mai, and Maki and underwent a heavenly restriction
to greatly increase his physical capabilities,
then somehow re-entered the world
of Jujutsu? From this, though,
it's obvious that he was an outcast
from birth, an unwanted little wretch.
For those curious about a major part of what
Jujutsu Kaisen is about, it is all about teaching
people what love is. It sounds soppy and cringe,
but it's this underlying part of the story that,
now with a lot of the most loved characters
beginning to fall or having fallen, is making
itself even more apparent. To me, Sukuna fears
death because he is the strongest. He thinks you
are alone in death, which also is crazy after what
happened recently. We saw that in Jujutsu Kaisen,
when you die, you aren't alone; you are surrounded
by all of your loved ones, be it in this world or
the next, human or cursed spirit. Jogo upon
death instantly found his close friends,
and so did Gojo with his entire year from school;
even freaking Toji was there. I don't know, and
people are gonna find it weird, and it depends on
how Yuji talk-no-jutsu’s it, but the story began
with Yuji being taught what love is, and it's
probably going to end with him teaching Sukuna.
Enough of me talking about love though; it's time
for Kashimo to attempt it. Still in conversation,
he asks how Sukuna is able to connect with others,
how can he love those beneath him without
knowing some kind of weakness. To Kashimo,
it's something he just can't comprehend. He
was always surrounded by the most feeble and
pathetic people, no more than dirt in the eyes of
cursed energy or pebbles of sand on a beach. In
an attempt to understand, he pleads with Sukuna
to enlighten him. Is strength itself solitude,
or is the endless search for greater power
simply a burden the strong have to bear alone?
Amused with just how greedy Kashimo is for
information on who he was, Sukuna chuckles
but lets him know that he’ll teach him, so be
sure to give him his best shot. Absolutely stoked
with the chance of a lifetime and something he
personally has wanted for hundreds of years,
Kashimo bursts forth. Jumping up,
he slams his staff down atop Sukuna,
only for him to comfortably block with an electric
burst before darting out of striking range.
Activating his one-time-use innate technique,
Kashimo releases his awed-over Mythic Beast:
Amber and proceeds to sock a shocked Sukuna with
a flurry of punches, sending him sliding back.
Warping his body into an otherworldly form,
Kashimo directs his face at his opponent and
sends a blast of electricity that explodes
upon contact with him. Joking that this form
of his is far too loud, it's explained that
Mythic Beast Amber transforms Kashimo’s body
into something else. I kind of think of
it like Ino’s Auspicious Beast Technique,
but instead of being an intermediary, Kashimo
literally becomes one of these Mythic beasts,
warping his body with cursed energy
to resemble it, in this example,
the Amber version. During the time this ability
is active, Kashimo can use any phenomena that
can be created by electricity until his cursed
energy runs out. I just want to mention that
this means it's possible Kashimo can travel at 90
percent the speed of light or over 250,000 km/s.
Using this speed increase to his advantage,
Kashimo takes Sukuna somewhat by surprise
and sends a blast of sonic electricity into
the ground directly below him. Instantly
following this, Kashimo throws a fat right
hook, connecting with Sukuna’s face,
leaving him flattened upon the ground.
It's explained that by activating this technique,
Kashimo’s agility increases. He can optimize
the sound and tune out incorrect noises to
match natural frequencies. If any object
is sent at him, it's quickly vaporized due
to the electromagnetic waves flowing off his
body. Yet, once this technique concludes and
because of how badly Kashimo’s body is being
exerted, he will crumble to dust and die.
Using an effect of his own cursed energy and
having placed a positive charge on Sukuna when
he hit him, Kashimo releases the negative
one and sends a current of electricity
that instantaneously connects with the
king of curses' already weakened body.
Apart from the reverse cursed technique, Sukuna
has a secret method of restoring his original
body. One that he isn't able to abuse and can
only use a single time. A certain method that
he had been intentionally waiting to use,
SINCE THE BEGINNING! This method was, like
the other members of the culling game, resuming
his transformation through means of incarnation!
Activating his X-Ray vision, Kashimo is
able to analyze the slowly approaching
demon. Without a doubt, what stood
in front of him was perfection.
When it comes to just how broken Sukuna
actually is, everyone needs to realize
that the reason he has extra body parts
and possibly internal organs is so that
his hands remain uninhibited. Then, while
performing a chant, his lungs remain free,
and his heart isn't burdened by the added effects.
All of these extra body parts provide Sukuna with
an immense advantage over anyone else. He may
be physically deformed, but that doesn't matter
or impede him in the slightest. Instead, as
I've mentioned, it adds to his potential.
During the Heian period, Sukuna was armed
with both his incredible strength and the
cursed tools known as Supreme Martial
Solution and Hiten. Hiten is supposedly
the large trident-like staff that he wields,
whereas the Kamutoke that Yorozu created is
most likely the recreation of
the Supreme Martial Solution.
With these items, Sukuna annihilated The
Sun, Moon, and Stars squad and the five
void generals that served as guards to the
northern Fujiwara clan. Then, on top of that,
he decisively defeated the Abe clan's
elite forces, which included Angels and the
Desshi Pacification Squad, who themselves
were composed of Sugawara clan members.
Utterly blown away with the unreal achievements
Sukuna was able to complete over his life,
Kashimo can only fawn over how beautiful
the demon king's true form seems.
Taking the offensive himself now, Sukuna rushes
Kashimo and manages to land a double right handed
body strike that launches the sorcerer up into
the sky. Using the height to his advantage,
Kashimo shoots a blast of condensed electricity
directly at his foe. Unconcerned, Sukuna with his
second mouth begins chanting, while simultaneously
telling Kashimo that he should probably dodge
this strike. Out of nowhere, Dismantle is sent
forth and manages to slice the palm of Kashimo’s
improved mythic beast form. Instantly, the
special grade sorcerer realizes that this
is the same ability that was able to finish Gojo
off, as it was a slash that cut the world itself.
Standing there, absolutely JACKED out of his mind,
Sukuna jokes that a fool once tried to teach him
about love. Yet, she didn't even know what love
was and was also insanely lonely. Sukuna explains
that he understood what she was trying to say;
however, she just had the wrong guy. In his eyes,
she'd have had more luck preaching her love
to someone like Kashimo or Gojo. It's not
that they didn't know what love was; it was
more that they were unable to understand it.
Completely confused with what he was
trying to say, Kashimo queries him,
only for Sukuna to ask him a bold
question in itself. He was strong, right?
Powering up as if it's his last chance, Kashimo
unleashes waves of electricity that shoot out
in every direction. Undeterred by the power
increase, Sukuna catches Kashimo off-guard and
appears right behind him, grabbing his hands
and pummeling him with the two free ones.
Coughing up blood now, Sukuna slams him
to the ground and throws the demonstrably
weaker sorcerer across the decimated landscape
of Shinjuku. Pulling up his hand in preparation
for his next cursed electricity blast,
Kashimo is left stunned. In front of
him now and with seemingly no escape,
a bunch of world-slashing dismantles,
all overlapping to form a net, rush
forth like a torrential wave of death.
Flashing away to a place that probably feels
more like home than anything for Kashimo, he
hears someone speaking some wise words behind him.
Many of the world's strongest fighters must have
challenged him. Still, with all of their strength
and spiritual dominance, they never cursed him in
death. In actuality, it's more that they just
wanted recognition from him. Then that would
give them an understanding of what they are truly
worth. Yet, he butchered every last one of them,
all while simultaneously wondering how he was
to properly care for others. In the eyes of the
wise Sukuna, if that isn't loving-kindness,
then what else could it even be? He knows
that most people love them for the strength
they possess, then they respond to that love.
Speaking up now and wondering if Sukuna's
satisfied, Kashimo asks if that is the case,
then queries why did he decide to divide
his soul and move through time as a cursed
object. Understanding this, Sukuna just tells
him that love is worthless. Through life,
he's never needed anyone to satisfy him.
He eats when he wants and plays with
whatever amuses him. He lives
life as it befits his nature,
and if no one is able to get that through
their thick noggins, that's their problem.
Chuckling with Sukuna’s explanation,
Kashimo just asks him if it ever gets old,
but is quickly told that it doesn't. Every
human has a unique and exuberant taste,
which makes devouring them a perfect way
to pass the time until death arrives.
I want to point out that, unlike when Gojo
died, Kashimo wasn't surrounded by all his
loved friends and family, just Sukuna.
Kinda reminded me of the Jogoat death
moment with just how quickly he was living then
in the shadow realm. Wish we got to see more,
but this is realistic; thinking Kashimo was going
to last even a third as long as Gojo is nuts.
Either way, and back in reality now with Hakari’s
Domain shattering, Sukuna turns to see a certain
someone arriving on the battlefield. Dropping
in from the sky, both Yuji and Higuruma ready
themselves to face off against the strongest
entity in the history of Jujutsu Kaisen.
This is going to be hella interesting. No idea
what Yuji has in store for us with his new cursed
technique or whatever it is, and Sukuna is on
the same page, wondering what the hell he's gonna
do here. I don't want to see Higuruma close the
series out by sticking Sukuna on death row; that
just doesn't feel right to me, especially after
the dude managed to get around Gojo’s infinity.
I'm curious about your thoughts on everything
below. Did you want to see more from Kashimo,
or did you expect his final technique to be a bit
more potent? This might be a case of an insanely
strong technique in the wrong person, kinda like
when we saw Jogo display his powers for the second
time in Shibuya, which was utterly insane compared
to episode 7 where Gojo dunked on him. If you want
to see more content like this, but for a bunch
of different series, then make sure to hit that
subscribe button. We're getting pretty close to
200k now, which is dope asf, so it'd be cool if
we could get there by Christmas! Either way, hit
the like button if you enjoyed the video. For now,
it's been your professional degenerate
Diavolo, and I'll see you all in a bit. Bye.